the smell of apple cider donuts fresh
fruit right for the picking and
Instagram worthy views we can only be
talking about the Gilcrease Orchard in
the Northwest Valley in fact the farm
starts its full hours today our Candace
Charles been there all morning long did
you come down from your sugar high off
of that donut Candace
no not at all
music here
absolutely right just take a look at all
of these sunflowers here it's actually
the most of flowers that the orchard has
had and you know what I've been able to
walk around and try some of the fruit as
well you guys are exactly right a lot to
try a lot to pick out and a lot to eat
so much fall fun here at Gilcrease
Orchard now of course I'm joined by
Marco Rubin now you guys have more
sunflowers than usual how did this
happen well when we pulled out the
tomatoes after the heat just killed them
all then we thought well let's just put
sunflowers in where the tomatoes were so
that's why we have so many and this is
not even even all of it right no but we
have more coming okay so we have have a
lot right now but there's more on the
way okay and then how did Moon soon
season help so monsoon season helped a
lot because it was a higher humidity
okay and lower temperatures and that's
what the plant's like so it was more
like the Midwest instead of the desert
yeah it gets really hot out here I know
but now we're feeling a little bit of
the Fall Vibes may not be the exact
temperature and you guys can come down
here and enjoy this all this starting
today as well as
Tuesdays Thursdays Saturdays and Sundays
from 7 A.M to 2 p.m yes and
so I think the perfect days are Tuesdays
and Thursdays at seven o'clock okay so
if you're dropping the kids off at
elementary school and it starts at nine
come before and then
you have the fall experience absolutely
I love it thank you so much Mark for
chatting with us this morning I
appreciate it I'd love to see you and do
here at Gilcrease Orchard and of course
we got you covered with all the details
times and a little bit about the new
entrance and exit as well as Whispering
is it Sands the spring Sands what spring
Sand Drive you guys want to remember
that as well again all details for you
on 8newsnow.com for now I'm Candace
Charles 8 News Now